it being a little bit late we're going
to start
got a little problem there um it being a
little bit late we're going to start and
uh call
um the executive session of the uh house
fish and game committee into order we're
going to take the bills down in
numerical order from top to bottom as
they show up on your sheet right before
that
the clerk would like us
sure
absolutely so we'll take we'll take a
minute and allow the clerk to do a roll
call to find out which members are
present and which substitutes we have
and who they're substituting for um so
i'll turn it over to clerk to go ahead
and uh do a vote
call thank you mr chair uh
representative khan
thank you representative close
representative spelaine
representative howard
representative craig
representative allard
representative smith
representative harvey
representative leflam
representative masamila substituting for
representative dottonville
representative king
the clerk is here representative egan
representative shirtless
i believe representative ellis is absent
do we not have a substitute
okay and representative oxel
thank you miss clerk you're all ready
and ready to go for that
all right great
so uh we're in executive session we're
going to be going through the bills and
we'll open each bill individually have a
conversation about it make motions and
go forward um i'm going to make one
comment to the members i went back and
listened to some of our
um january 14th conversation the one
thing i learned was that if you're not
talking straight into the mic
nobody in the in the youtube world can
hear what you're saying on motion so i'd
ask you that when we're voting and when
you're speaking to make sure you're
talking directly into the mic and when
you're all done
kill it make sure the red light's off
because we only have three mics on out a
time the fourth person
won't be able to speak so make sure you
remember to turn your mic off with that
being said let's go and jump right into
the order of days or any other business
we need to do before we jump in
the bills
so thank you very much
representative would you lead us into
no please no we're not doing a national
anthem
um all right first up is house bill 1297
i'm going to open the executive session
on house bill 1297 relative to the
taking of lobster while engaged in
recreational scuba diving um to start
the discussion i'm going to recognize
representative spelaine for the purpose
of emotion
thank you mr chair i move otp it's been
moved otp
and representative love nice second it's
been seconded by representative love
the bill is now on the table as an otp
and is open to further amendment uh
recognize representative spelaine
thank you mr chair i have an amendment
that was uh drafted that you should have
in front of you
the amendment simply puts
the ability to regulate the seasons uh
and bag limits in the direct rulemaking
authority a fishing game so that it's
not hard coded and there's no specific
period of time or bag limit and fishing
game can manage it based on how they
manage all their other species
thank you representative spelaine any
further comment i would move the
amendment thank you it is uh
two zero two two
so representatives playing have moved
amendment zero one five seven h is there
a second i'll second that seconded by
representative love and it's open for
discussion
um representative spelaine would you
like to speak to your amendment again
okay as i said uh mr chair this uh
this
simply gives rule making authority uh to
regulate the
taking of lobster by diving to the fish
and game uh department so that the
director can set in rules what the the
bag limit and or
season is through the normal process
thank you
any further comment on
hb 12
97 and amendment 157 representative
harvey
thank you um
i do appreciate the amendment i think
the um i agree with the representative
that it is up to fish and game to set uh
limits and seasons and so forth however
i attend
as many commission meetings as i can and
this year i even attended the
legislative
our present legislation was presented
and public input was allowed to be given
and the
person who spoke
for marine fisheries was very
adamant
that there were problems with this even
with the amendment and she listed them
very clearly
one was
that if scuba divers are searching for
lobsters they could possibly
disturb underwater habitat which to me
is
a problem
she also mentioned that our juvenile
lobsters are on decline and so this
would
further that decline also maybe put our
lobster uh fisherman at
um a disadvantage and then there's the
enforcement issue of you can't
look at a trap when you realize that
there's a diver down below you can't
bring a boat up to there to to check a
trap so i i will not be able to support
this um
even with the amendment thank you
representative reed
thank you mr chair
um i too was concerned initially when we
first heard the testimony about the
disturbing of lobster breeding grounds
and the sediment
and potentially
i guess almost cruel manner of taking
but we heard from one of the most
preeminent wildlife biologists and
conservationists in the state weldon
bosworth whose
conservation
and knowledge i i absolutely it's
unimpeachable
and
not only did he describe the actual
method of take which involves and other
divers did too which involves teasing
them out but further and i believe we
might have more information to this
divers are currently allowed to take
crab crab
occupy the same areas as the lobster and
the method of take is the same as well
given that and the knowledge that the
divers who are interested in this
actually are scheduling a meeting with
the advisory committee to go into detail
i think it is probably good that we
allow this to go through with the
amendment and allow the senate to
fine-tune anything that they might
discover in meeting
thank you representative reid
representative spelaine is recognized
thank you mr chair um to representative
reed's point
i will point the committee to uh rsa 211
colon 18-c crabs
notwithstanding any provisions of this
chapter to the contrary any person may
take 12 crabs a day by angling diving or
by hand
so fish and game already
checks divers when they come up to make
sure they've only got 12 crabs they've
already got the ability to count to 12
so they can count to any number that we
set for lobsters and i don't think
there's any problem where they can
already take crab it's already in our
statute
let him take some lobsters as well
thank you
representative shirtless
thank you mr chairman mr chairman i
understand we are only voting on the
amendment right now
that is correct that's the motion that's
on the floor is the amendment
i think the amendment actually makes the
bill better
uh and i will vote for the amendment but
i will be voting against octopass as
amended thank you mr chairman
thank you
shirtless representative
khan
mr chairman i'll wait when that comes to
the real
bill
any further discussion on the amendment
the motion is adoption of amendment zero
one five seven h
excuse me one second clerk i apologize
members please remember to use your mic
and speak into the mic so that people
who are watching and listening and the
and the permanent record will can be
able to hear your vote
thank you the answer is yes
thank you
representative close yes
representative spelaine
yes
representative howard
representative craig
yes
representative love
representative wolf
yes
representative kittridge
representative allard
yes
representative smith
representative harvey
yes
representative laflem yes
representative massimila
yes
representative king
oh sorry the clerk votes yes
representative egan yes
representative shertliff yes
representative voxel
yes
the vote is 18-0
chair votes yes oh i'm sorry the vote is
19-0
i have to scroll all the way back up to
see you mr chair
on a vote the 19-0 the amendment is
adopted we're on to an otp otpa motion
now
on house bill 1297 and is open to
further debate and discussion well
actually
it's already otp and we adopt an
amendment the new motion is otpa
so it's just we're discussing the amen
we're discussing the bill as amended at
this point uh representative vegan you
have a question no i have commentary on
this
thank you mr chair
um i have two con grave concerns with
this bill mr chair
we already know have heard in many
testimonies of many bills in front of
fish and game the lack or reduction in
workforce and the number of conservation
officers that are needed to
supply the state with the safety and
there's a concern that we are going to
stretch them even more thin when they
have to walk the beaches to try and
check on making sure that
egg-filled mother lobsters aren't being
taken accidentally by novice
lobstermen
i was glad to hear that the
in the professional sense are welcoming
conservation officers and marine um
resource officials to come on their
boats and check their catches and
educate them if they are making errors
and i think that
is a good thing that happens and a good
use of their time and by allowing
individuals to then catch lobsters on
the beach it's going to stretch their
time even thin
time that we already know is stretched
in through the lack of conservation
officers that we fund in the state and i
have a grave concern on how that will
begin to affect the bigger picture of
safety
the second one is actually a safety
issue
i have three close friends that are
scuba divers
no one is ever directly under their flag
where it's posted
that means there's a diver in the area
my concern is
if folks want to
scuba dive to catch lobsters they're not
going to go out in the middle of the
ocean where nobody is they're going to
go where they think the lobsters are
that means they're going to go near
where the lobstermen's boats are
which means they could get tangled in
cages tangled in ropes and i think it's
a safety issue for me in terms of
allowing them to get access to areas
that
fishermen
are working and
it it just bothers me i i know that
scuba divers are safe minded folks but
they're never directly under their flag
so fishermen will not know exactly where
they are and if they're looking for
lobsters they may not exactly know where
all the lobstermen's traps are so those
two concerns of the amount of staff that
would take to police this bill and the
safety concerns
i think you can understand that i would
not be able to support this bill thank
you
thank you representative representatives
matt can you turn your mic off
um
representative reed
thank you mr chair in terms of the
safety concerns what i understand from
the many states that already allow this
is this has almost never been an issue
and i certainly trust the department to
be able to regulate
how close a diver is allowed to get to a
boat or vice versa
in terms of the rest i again i when i
first heard the testimony
i was kind of surprised because my
natural instinct would be to think that
commercial operations would be far more
disruptive than um then single
individual
diver taking in in a way very similar to
how they've done it for thousands of
years
and um
again after i heard the testimony of the
divers and weldon bosworth again whose
conservation
understanding cannot be is just
unquestionable
it seems that my original suspicion that
in fact those individuals cause far less
disruption to the natural environment is
actually correct and i can understand
how the commercial
lobster industry might have a lot of
pull and
influence with the department but
for those reasons i will be supporting
otpa
thank you representative reed
representative spelaine
thank you mr chair
i will
direct once again uh in the con in
answer to the comment that the fish and
game doesn't have enough staff to police
it
rsa2118
c
we're already
taking crab by diving and fish and game
is already monitoring that situation
there's no extra staff situation that i
see
necessary when they're already checking
divers for their take on crab
in response to the
diver safety situation i will point out
that no diver's going to dive and look
for crab in the wide open water where
the traps were likely going to be laid
they tend to dive closer to shore along
the cliff lines and such and then tickle
the lobsters out with a tickle stick so
that they can take them by hand
you won't find lobster boats fishing
right next to the rocks on the shore
because that's where they're going to
get damaged and they're not going to lay
a trap there because it's it's not a
good place to drop a trap where it can
get caught in the rocks
so that's my testimony and i will be
supporting otpa
thank you representative explaining
representative khan
thank you mr chairman i have the equal
concern about about this bill
that other representative mentioned
about the safety
and also
that uh we're gonna
we might
in the process we might
destroy the habitat
uh
see uh new hampshire sea coast is very
small sea coast like just say 17 mile
the lobster industry is working very
well
um
it's we should be happy the way things
are going we if we touch this
we might be
you know we might be
destroying the industry and you know
uh we'll be sorry and later so i i'm not
going to vote for this bill
thank you representative any further
discussion representative harvey
thank you and i do appreciate the
information concerning the crab industry
um and
the idea that we hunt crabs so therefore
we should be able to
have lobsters as well but but none of
that um addresses the issue that was
brought up at fish and game concerning
the decline in juvenile lobsters and
um
this this is a bill that would hasten
that decline thank you
any further comments or questions
singing on the chair is going to just
make a statement
again you know on this amendment on this
bill i have every faith and fish and
game and all the right regulations build
and manage species and manage what's
going on within their staffing concerns
and everything else
i believe that you know when you talking
about the taking of lobster
especially when you bring in the fact
that we take crab in a similar manner
with crab pots and and by taking that
the method isn't any different um
currently the same dive regulations
about where a boat can go if a man's
just out diving is the same whether
taking lobster or not right you have to
maintain a certain distance so that
doesn't change anything about the safety
evolving the interaction between
divers and lobstermen
the last thing i'll say it was clear
from the testimony that we heard that
the environmental police in
massachusetts have had zero reported
cases of incidents between
lobstermen and scuba divers right they
haven't had this this isn't hasn't been
a problem um they were more likely to
have an incentive lobster and a
lobsterman than they were between a
lobster and a fisherman so
i think the the bill goes way to
supporting our citizens and their right
to not have to own a sixty thousand
dollar boat or more to be able to go out
and take lobster uh and and use that
natural resources we have here in new
hampshire um and i again lastly i i have
every firm confidence and belief that
fish and game will manage it through the
regulatory process and rules that'll go
before jalcar and have another
legislative look um
to support this this uh program so with
that being said we're gonna move to a
vote madam clerk if you could call the
roll the motion is otpa on house bill
thank you
representative close yes
representative spelaine
yes
representative howard
yes representative craig
yes representative love
um can you speak into your microphone
yes thank you representative kittredge
yes representative ollard yes
representative smith yes
representative harvey
no
representative king
representative egan
no
and representative axel
and mr chair
chair votes yes
with a vote 11 to 8 the uh house bill
1297 passes an otpa motion will there be
a minority report and who will be
so representative horribly your drafting
minority report rep spelaine will be
drafting a majority report
please have those to us by the end of
if i can just have a second to write
representative harvey is the motion itl
all right i'm ready all right next up is
house bill 1299 so i'm going to close
the executive session on house bill 1297
and open the executive center house bill
um
the chair will make a motion of otp
look to represent the craig second
so it's been moved otp on house bill
1299 seconded by representative craig
the chair will further move amendment
number
2022-01508
second
been moved and seconded uh for the
amendment it's open to further
discussion and debate uh i'll just speak
to my amendment um so again this bill i
want to be careful we talk about
invasive species and and and and putting
the herd at risk and all of those
conversations we heard in the last in in
the public hearing but the reality is
this is a process bill this isn't about
the denial or the approval process this
is just about the fact that we want to
process in place we heard testimony from
the last gentleman
of the day
where he was denied a permit from
fish and game and then there was a dead
end there was no place to go he had he
had
conflicting science he wanted to present
and basically was told no we don't care
we're not going to do it and i felt that
was an inappropriate action
and that there should be some sort of
process for citizens who um again were
leaning on the executive driver director
heavily so he makes that ruling as a
singer and he's responsible for it as a
single individual and that there should
be an appeal process for that so this is
about an appeal process and about the
permitting process
and requiring fish and game to respond
in a timely fashion six i expanded by
the amendment the amendment expands it
to 60 days which i think is reasonable
in my conversation with colonel jordan
this morning he felt that was a
reasonable accommodation to move it out
to 60 days
they already have their list of species
that are denied right just outright
because they know it's a problem
and they can still rely on that and
immediately deny a permit
but it allows the citizen the ability to
if they feel the denial is
not based in science and i'm going to
give you an example as to why this bill
came forward
is in that conversation that last
fish and game on their website has
cdw free states listed
which means that pryon disease doesn't
exist in those states by whatever means
they determine that prion disease
doesn't exist in those states
the gentleman that was trying to import
the reindeer was importing from one of
those states and yet the very reason
that fish and game gave was they were
afraid of prion disease from a state
that is listed on their website is not
having prion disease so there was
conflict there in the science and and
there was no place to turn it was once
the gnaw was given it was given and
there was no place to go
and so the idea behind this bill is to
give our citizens the right to have a
hearing a secondary hearing if they
disagree like in this case there was
conflict in the direct science efficient
game in one place on their website they
said there's no prion disease and
another and yet they were denying
a permit based on prion disease didn't
it's it's illogical on its face
and so this bill came out of that um and
again it's a process it's not about
prion disease it's about making sure
citizens have good processes in the
state and have the ability to be heard
so with that i'll open up to any other
comments or questions
rep
representative khan
thank you mr chairman i had concern
about this bill when we were hearing the
testimony last time we we met here but
because of this amendment and it
satisfied me i'm going to vote it vote
yes on this bill
thank you representative khan any
further discussion representative reid i
have a genuine real question of the
chair um so i remember in the testimony
that this was changing the default
position to yes does the amendment
change that
so the amendment is is the same so again
that it requires fish and game respond
one of the one of the problems with the
current law was that they could hold the
permit for six months they could hold it
for a year there was no requirement for
them to actually act
and so we wanted to change i wanted to
change that i want to
if someone is looking to do something
they shouldn't have to wait a year for
fish and game to respond yes or no
and so what this bill does is it
defaults it to yes if fish and game does
not respond within 60 days then the
default answer is yes they get their
permit
it puts an onus on fish and game to
actually act on the citizens request
any further discussion on this bill
we're voting uh i'm sorry representative
sherliff go ahead
thank you mr chairman
as before i'm going to vote for the
amendment because the amendment does
improve the bill
um but on the underlying bill the otpa
motion i'll vote against it uh what i
would like to see is this bill go to
interim study i think an appeals process
is necessary but i think it's something
needs a little bit more work and
i'm not even sure if the 60 days is
adequate and i would like to hear from
fish and game in testimony about that
aspect so as i said i'll vote again for
the amendment vote against the bill and
i hope there'll be a motion for interim
study thank you mr chair thank you
representative harvey
i
i do believe the amendment makes it
better 60 days though to me that
actually sounds short um considering the
staffing
issues at fish and game i'd probably
like to see 90 days um and i do question
that in the underlying bill if the fish
and game commission
i i do think there should be an appeals
process but i'm i question rather the
fish and game commission is the right
and so i also because of that we'll
vote for the amendment
but i don't
plan to vote for the underlying bill
i would prefer interim study because
again i think 60 days is actually too
short and um i'd like to have more time
to think about this and have more input
on on that from
uh fish and game thank you
thank you ever just to answer your
question about that so again i did have
a conversation efficient game and
understanding that in their 800 rules
that they have they have a pretty
exciting pretty substantial list of you
just can't bring these animals in which
they would use as their basis and every
time they review they're only going to
be reviewing the animals that aren't on
that list and every time they review an
animal that's not on their list guess
where it's going to be added to their
list if they deny it so that list will
grow and with time and make the process
easier and easier as fish and game goes
along and the only animals they need the
60 days for the ones that are not on the
list that are already in their rules so
just to make it understand that it's not
like they have to take every single
species and investigate it they've
already done a significant portion of
the work and it's already in rules and
they can still rely on that for their
denial process so it's only the
incremental new animals that aren't on
their list that they need time to
research and i think 60 days to research
an animal is pretty reasonable
thank you representative reed
thank you mr chair i i was going to
reserve my comments for discussion on
the bill but i guess we are we're
discussing both at once so i mean
obviously the amendment makes it better
i do think 60 days is probably
reasonable based on what we heard during
the hearing
i understand the commission doesn't want
to be that body but there's really no
one else to put it before if the
executive director is the person saying
no the only entity to go to after that
is the commission really
my my concern and i understand why this
was placed in the bill because this is
kind of the stick right that it has to
be you have to respond or it's going to
default to yes but i i am still a little
bit uneasy about that default to yes
because if paperwork gets lost or
something could someone bring in a
species and as we all know it only takes
one species when one member of a species
even to bring in something that's
potentially devastating to our ecosystem
or even human health so i'm i'm
genuinely torn because i do think this
this needs to be addressed um but i'm
still kind of nervous about the default
any further discussion
so we're voting on the amendment
amendment number
[Music]
five 2022-0150 h
um and i'll have the clerk call the roll
thank you
yes
representative close yes
representative spelaine yes
representative howard
yes
representative craig
representative love
yes representative wolf
yes
representative kittredge
representative allard
yes
representative smith
representative harvey
yes
representative laflem
representative masamila yes
representative king
yes
the clerk votes yes representative egan
representative shirtless
yes
and representative oxal
yes and mr chair chair vote yes
the vote is 19-0 i vote the 19-0
amendment number zero one five zero is
adopted and we're on to an otp otpa
motion
of the original bill and it's open for
further discussion
anybody who covers anything the one
thing i'll remind members is that this
this isn't the end of the bill
it still goes over to the senate and
still has a conversation still open to
amendment over in the senate
so again if members feel that the bill
has merit um they can still go over to
the senate and help
and and amend the concerns out of the
bill that you have over there so
representative harvey
thank you and i understand that it does
bother me a little bit though that um
we do our work and then hope that the
senate will fix it i i would prefer that
we do the best work what we can and send
that over rather than um
saying well
there may or may not be problems so
maybe you guys can can do something
about it i still would like to see an
interim study for this because there
seems to be some concerns that were
brought forward and
i think those concerns
should be answered and could be answered
through an interim study thank you
thank you and i might be a little biased
representing the shirtless thank you mr
chairman mr chim and
just to echo the comments of the member
from new market i agree that the
idea that it's an automatic yes if fish
and game does not act within the timely
manner
is concerning and i
know that our friend and colleague on
this committee from newport uh newberry
remembers decades ago when someone had
the bright idea of taking a pill full of
rock bass and dumping him into lake
sunapee
and that now it completely destroyed the
lake sunapee trout
and i hate to see someone get an
automatic pass to
import something that could be an
invasive species and cause damage to our
new hampshire wildlife so i'll be voting
now and again my hope is that there'd be
a motion to come forward for interim
study thank you mr chairman
thank you
representable flam go ahead
thank you mr chair
um i also agree with the
representative
from newmarket and the representative
from penacook
and i would like to add the fact that
through rsas and through rulemaking
we
we have given the executive director
certain powers to make
decisions and i really don't like the
idea
of the fish and game commission being
able to override decisions on the
executive made by the executive director
i understand um the neces the necessity
of it of an appeal process
um but i'm really
uncomfortable
with the fish and game commission
um being given power to override
decisions
that are granted to the executive
further comments
representative love
yeah regarding the the pail of rock bass
that were dumped in sunapee uh i doubt
they looked for for any permits to do it
um you know people
people have done that in the northern
part but uh back lake for instance uh
rock bass is a is an invasive species in
winnipesaukee
those people didn't
i don't think they came to fish and
games asking if we can dump these in and
they'll continue to do those things um
representative khan thank you mr
chairman i understand this bill doesn't
give any permission to bring anything in
new hampshire it only does is
uh that we respond to our citizens uh
fish and game or fish and game
commission even this committee we all
work for the citizens so we have right
citizens have the right to know our
decision you know in promptly so that's
so just chair i'll reserve the last
comment um again this is a process bill
um this is about recognizing our
citizens that they have a right to be
responded to by our state agencies and
not be held up for undeterminable amount
of time
um
and you know i i think this is a good
process bill while i recognize
representative leflam's
comment about the the commission bottom
line is the commission is the policy arm
right they we every bill we see comes
with a commission recommendation on
setting policies so they set policy on a
regular basis or they established a
policy what efficiency what is going to
happen in fish and game so giving them a
policy decision or evaluating a decision
made by the agency head
i don't think is unreasonable i think
again it's it's not out of the
wheelhouse these are the policies
they're already discussing um on on what
when when rulemaking authority occurs
the commission weighs in on what animals
are added to that list um on the
adoption of rules so again i i think
this is a this is well within the
commission's policy uh wheelhouse of
looking at what's going on and how it's
responding to our citizens and whether
the science is accurate or not because
they're almost presuming they're already
looking at science to establish our
policies and making evaluations on that
so i think this is again a process bill
it's not about any individual species
it's about making sure our citizens are
heard and obviously i'll be voting yes
to the otpa motion
mr vice chair
yes thank you
representative close yes representative
spelaine
yes representative howard
yes representative craig
yes representative love yes
representative wolf yes representative
kittridge
yes representative allard yes
representative smith
yes
representative harvey
no
representative leflam
representative masamila
no
representative king
the clerk
votes
no
representative egan
yes
representative shirtless
no
representative oxal
yes
and
rep mr chair
yes
the vote is
on a vote 11-8 um who will be writing
the minority report the the bill is as
amended as adopted and going to the
house with odpa recommendation yes
could the clerk
double check the roll call vote because
i come up with a different number thank
you
no
count is apparently 12 to 7
right no
13 to 6.
yes
13 to 6. all right thank you
apparently fish and game count to 12 but
we're having problems in our committee
um
so uh with the vote being 13 to 6 the
otp motion will be the recommendation of
the committee to the whole house
on a minority who's going to write the
seeing no other hand i guess i am
representative haru be writing a
minority report i'll be writing a
yes sir mr chairman is a minority
report required on every vote
they can choose to waive it okay that i
just wanted to do yep you can choose if
you're going to write one i need to know
that if you're not then i need to know
that just so i can plan i just want to
make that clear we've asked for the last
two bills or the last couple of bills
for minority reports and sometimes it
may not be a minority report
absolutely so know that minority can
wave off just unfortunately there has to
be a majority report but the minority
report can write off thank you mr
chairman
and with that i close the executive um
executive session on house bill 1299 and
move on to house bill 1308 and recognize
representative howard and i opened the
executive session house bill 1308 and i
recognize representative howard for a
motion
mr i'd like to make a motion of itl on
it's been moved itl by representative
howard and he's seconded by
second representative allard
um the motion on the floor motion in the
committee is itl on house bill 1308 and
seeing none uh
clerk are you looking for time you're
looking for you want to say something i
need i do need time but i do want to say
something um i have i guess it's
impossible to move it now because i was
typing but i do have an amendment i
don't want to kill this bill the
amendment um
not only
gets rid of the seizure of hair
which solves the potential
constitutional issue but what it does is
it allows the existing clubs to continue
to train on their own
uh live hairs that they have they made
quite a bit of testimony about how they
had veterinarian checks that they were
taking care of these animals properly
that they were breeding
reasonably well and if that's the case
they should be able to propagate their
own now having said that i had heard
comments about
well what about the gene pool and what
about if there's kind of a mass
extinction event there are five
different clubs if they each have a
population of hair that they're
propagating they can trade keep that
gene bull fresh and act as they back up
for each other so i prefer to see the
amendment
adopted which allows the clubs to
continue doing everything they're
currently doing
and
yet takes away the ability to just go
and take an animal out of out of the
wild which really nobody else gets to do
like we we say you can't take an animal
out of the wild for pleasure but for
some reason one group is allowed to so
i just wanted to talk to my
amendment i don't suspect it will change
anything but i wanted to put it out
there for the record
thank you representative any further
discussion on the itl motion on house
bill 1308
so
representative harvey so i just want to
be clear we we are not voting on the
amendment we are voting on the 1308 bill
correct that's correct she just wanted
to make the members aware that there was
an amendment if they wanted to vote
against the itl motion and bring a
different motion forward she wanted to
know that there's an amendment and i'll
just speak a little bit representative
reid and i did have a discussion about
that amendment and it was about the
constitutional argument i had about the
fact that we are taking property from
citizens without any kind of due process
through the law and that's a significant
problem
um and so
she wrote an amendment that dealt with
that due process issue basically saying
we're not going to take the animals and
you don't have to set them free um and
but i still find that it's
the problem i have with the amendment or
going forward in otp motion is the fact
that
it's a dead-end road
um for the for the clubs right
ultimately they won't have any rabbits
and then it kills this kills eve it
kills the problem so um i i there's not
a solution that gives them light at the
end of the tunnel and i think it'll
that being said we'll go to
the vote madam clerk if you could call
the rule
mr vice chair yes
this
representative spelaine
yes
representative howard
representative craig
yes representative love yes
representative kittredge
yes representative ballard yes
representative smith yes
representative leflam
yes
the clerk votes no
representative egan yes
representative shirtless yes
representative oxel
yes
on a vote of 18-1 without objection will
next up i'll close the executive session
on house bill 1308 opening executive
session house bill 1323 right all of the
hike safe cars i recognize
there's been a motion of otp on house
bill 1323 made by representative
check it it's been moved by
representative spelaine seconded by
representative gettridge
otp on house bill 1323 and it's open to
further amendment recognize
sorry i don't know why my mike's dead
there was an amendment
that was
drafted
that pulls out everything that has to do
with um the daily weekly or any of that
stuff and all it does is simply
make the uh the bill now say that the
executive director can establish
the fee so i'm gonna move
it's been moved by representatives plain
uh to adopt amendment zero one
five one h and that's seconded by
and seconded by representative kittridge
is open to further discussion
uh i'll take i'll take an opportunity
i the hike safe program is a phenomenal
program within our state it's working
extremely well
what we're looking to do as long as we
had opened this chapter of law for
discussion i was looking to future-proof
the legislation to allow fish and game
to manage the program as they see fit
and not have fees set in statute that
are hard-coded and anytime they want to
change it they'd have to come back to us
and have a wait a year to two year
process to try to get something changed
so what we're just doing is we're
striking the language and the amendment
for the fees and we're just giving
administrative rules authority for them
to set their fees in their own rules so
they can manage the program better on a
so anybody else have any questions
seeing none we're voting on amendment
number 2022-0151
h the adoption of that amendment the
mr vice chair
representative close yes
representative spelaine yes
representative howard
yes representative craig
yes
representative love yes
representative wolf yes
representative kittridge
yes
representative allard yes
representative smith
yes
representative harvey yes
representative leflam yes
representative masamila yes
representative king yes
the clerk votes yes
representative egan yes
representative shurtleb yes
representative oxal
yes and mr chair
so on a unanimous vote uh the amendment
is adopted the new motion is ought to
pass as adapted
thank you mr chair i would just make
this comment that i think that the
amendment is a great thing it actually
fixes it to help the program be more
dynamic they can
now without coming back to the
legislature
to fix a rate or a fee that they need to
increase or decrease they can do that
themselves
and it also allows them flexibility
should they decide to set a fee for out
of state in the future that is a
different fee than we pay for residents
they can have a non-resident versus
resident fee structure it's completely
under the control of them now and they
can let this program grow as it
dynamically needs to grow
thank you
grab sam vegan
the best thing i can say for the fine
representative from uh representatives
pauline is i concur
complete
right on target i think this makes a
better bill and i'll support it
great thank you
any further discussion
on the motion of otpa ought to pass as
amended on house bill number
mr vice chair yes
representative close
yes representative spelaine yes
representative howard
yes representative craig yes
representative love yes representative
wolf yes representative kittredge yes
representative allard yes representative
smith yes representative harvey
sorry yes representative laflamme yes
representative masamila yes
representative king
yes the clerk votes yes representative
egan yes representative shirtless yes
representative oxal yes and mr chair
chair vote yes on an unanimous vote uh
motion of otpa is adopted as a committee
recommendation and without objection
we're going to close the
committee the executive session on house
bill 1323 and open the executive session
house bill 1356
and the chair is going to make a motion
of otp
looking to representative craig circuit
it's been moved by the chair of otp
seconded by representative craig has
opened a further amendment the chair
offers amendment number
zero one six six h um and looking for a
second second
so as we move to adopt amendment number
zero one six six h
and i'll speak to this amendment
so
the conference we had we had a
significant amount of conversation
around this bill
um one of our longer committee meetings
the thing that i took out of the bill
and what i've learned in doing this and
why i drafted this amendment is the
amount of damage
that gray squirrels do
to our to our agriculture community and
to our residents um as a whole the
damage to buildings and such
um the second thing i learned in this is
that with the exception of the beaver i
think this is the only rodent that we
actually have seasoned for
um that are all other red squirrels you
can hunt whatever you want
uh gophers you can hunt whenever you
want porcupines you can hunt whenever
you want but for some reason we've
pulled out gray squirrels and said no
we're going to set some sort of limited
season on grey squirrels
and and considering the damage i've done
i think we all remember
uh squirrel armageddon a couple years
ago where you couldn't go five five feet
down the road without seeing a flattened
squirrel
i don't believe that this is an
endangered species i don't think that
this is where we're in a problem that
we're gonna find we're short of grey
squirrels and on top of that we don't
live in tennessee i don't think there's
a there's a significant portion of our
hunting communities out there hunting
gray squirrels
so that being said i think it's
appropriate that we we not have a season
on this on this uh rodent
that people be allowed to take it uh
whenever they feel like it
that again it's not a it's not an
endangered species it's not a herd
population a deer population we're
trying to manage or a moose population
we're trying to manage the size of the
herd
and that um
they're not at risk of extinction by any
stretch of the imagination and i'm sure
our homeowners are having problems with
bird feeders and chicken coops and
everything else they'll also appreciate
the fact that they don't have to run the
risk of potentially being having to
prove that the reason they shot
a squirrel was because it was damaging
property and having to go through that
with fish and game now it's just going
to be if the squirrel's damaged you can
probably can shoot it you're not going
to run the risk of potentially being
charged with a crime
so
with that we'll open up a further
discussion representative harvey
thank you so i i have two two problems
um
we have heard numerous times this
morning and in the hearing which i did
attend via live stream by the way um
that it is up to fish and game to set
limits and seasons and so forth and that
we have um a great deal of confidence in
their ability and their wisdom in doing
so and yet this amendment takes that
away from them you are setting a season
of a non-season
um
and not letting them do exactly the job
that we've said all morning they're very
capable of doing so that that's an issue
i also um
have a little bit of a problem with
sometimes comparing animals
i think efficient game has done a great
job of setting seasons for each
individual animal whether it's a
squirrel or a porcupine or a fox or a
whatever
and not not trying to lump them together
because each one has its own
characteristics its own part in the food
chain and so forth so i i i don't
support this amendment at all thank you
thank you and i am going to answer the
question as to why i stepped aside from
this conversation of of
seasons and setting seasons for fish and
game and i i when i drafted this
amendment i had that exact argument in
mind i'm like i don't necessarily like
doing this
but
the reason i'm doing is because the
legislature has broad shoulders and this
issue has obviously created a pretty
significant divide
um between
our our various i won't say parties but
just issues of you know the animal
rights conservationists and hunters so
to speak
and that putting fish and game in that
political squabble for lack of a better
phrase i think is inappropriate is that
i think that the legislature has the
broad shoulders to take this on if we've
choose to pass this vote then we take
the weight on it and we take the weight
from those organizations and not fish
and game um i'd rather not put the
weight on fish and game and have them in
the middle of a political argument i'd
rather them in or a partisan argument so
to speak i'd rather them
focus on conserving the animals that our
deer
our fish are our moose our bear you know
all the other animals in the state that
aren't generally non-partisan
non-political right so they're not
nearly as as as as divided as we heard
the testimony on this bill
and so uh to answer your question the
reason i did is because i'm trying to
take weight off fishing game yes i
recognize that this is uh divergence
from the statement i usually make which
is they're doing a great job let them do
their job but in this case it's not
it's not as simple as science so to
speak um that there's passions that come
into play um honestly we heard it we had
two and a half hour argument or
discussion and and hear hearing on
lactating gray squirrels
and so
i think that
i want to take the weight off fishing
game i want to make this i'm going to
take the weight on and it's my amendment
and i'm the one that i think is is it's
appropriate for us to decide that this
is an inappropriate use of fission games
time and
have the bill pass representative reed
thank you mr chair um
we have this argument every year over
pretty much every bill to what extent do
we let fish and game do their jobs and
to what extent do we take over
this is certainly not the first time we
can go through any number of species
coyotes
bobcats you name it
however in the past the argument has
always been made
that
the commission did not decide in uh in
unison with their own biologists and
that's why we were putting forward bills
and had bills before us
this is something nobody's asked for in
fact for as far as damage done by
squirrels we already have rear round
open season on uh squirrels that do
damage we already can kill as many
squirrels that do damage as we want this
is specifically in regards to hunting
and
i have being from tennessee have tasted
squirrel meat myself
but in regards to hunting nobody has
asked for this now
i think good faith process usually
involves two sides attempting to move
towards each other understand each
other's arguments but instead what we
have is one side saying look this looks
like a typographical error everybody
around us is doing it at this time
why can't we move it two weeks one way
and then the other side going actually
we're going to make it the other extreme
from where it already was where it was
historically for the last 100 years
i just don't think that this is a good
process
and i will be voting against this
amendment
thank you representative ballard
representative craig thank you mr
chairman um
many of you won't know me because i am
very new to the committee and uh
actually i watched the testimony via
youtube
unable to be here
and i was concerned
about the
testimony that we were receiving
regarding uh some number of orphaned
baby squirrels
and so
being fortunate enough to to know a
small pool of retired wildlife
biologists both in new hampshire and
vermont i decided to consult my friends
on
what this issue might be
and i received two very
rapid responses
the first of which was
have you ever seen a squirrel hunter in
alluding to the fact that it is a very
small percentage of our small game
hunters who who actually hunt grey
squirrels
but the second was the most telling and
said if there are
orphaned baby squirrels
we need to look first at the tragedy of
roadkill
far
more of our squirrels are being taken
from the environment by our automobiles
than ever by a hunter and so
i i think this
this bill as originally proposed
would not solve that problem
uh because there just aren't the numbers
of of hunters that were going to change
the the numbers of orphans
versus automobiles so
i leave that
to your better judgment thank you
representative representative craig
thank you mr chair uh
i seem to recall that the motivation for
the underlying bill
was that
a complaint that the department was
a lack of satisfaction with the
department's response by not changing
the season
so i just find that an interesting
argument
that we should trust them
in now in opposition to the amendment
thank you represent representative flam
thank you mr chairman
um
just to refresh memories the original
bill
was
to allow
the hunting season for gray squirrels to
be
delayed
um
while they were
weaning their young
and
with all due respect mr chairman
uh this amendment
takes the weight off of fish and game
for deciding when the hunting season
should be
and basically have the legislature
declaring the grey squirrel as a gnosis
animal which should be hunted and killed
on site and i don't feel very good about
that thank you
any further discussion
seeing now we're voting on the adoption
of amendment
two zero two two zero one six six h the
mr vice chair yes
representative close
yes representative spelaine yes
representative howard
yes
representative craig yes
representative love yes
representative wolf
yes representative kittredge yes
representative allard yes
representative smith yes
representative harvey
no
thank you representative massimilia
yes
representative king
no
the clerk votes no representative egan
yes
representative oxel
no
one second please chair vote chess i'm
i'm i i was getting to you i just messed
up my numbers and mr chair
chair vote yes the vote is twelve to
seven
on a vote of 12-7
i'm sorry
the amendment is adopted
the new motion is ought to pass as
representative howard
thank you mr chair
these are a nuisance animal uh we've
heard a lot of testimony on this about
how much damage they do
um
for the most part hunters wouldn't hunt
them
in the summer anyways because you can't
see them up in the foliage
so i don't think hunting would have any
effect on their presence in the state
and i support the bill as a minute
thank you further discussion
representative laflamme
thank you mr chairman um
i'm going to vote no on the motion
um
otp as amended for the reasons i gave
earlier i think it's the purview and the
responsibility and the duty or whatever
you want to use the word for for fish
and game to declare
if gray squirrels should be hunted at
will
and it should not be something that the
thank you representative
thank you mr chair i do have to concur
with my colleague
that we talk a lot about the rule-making
authority of fishing game and not
stepping into their world and giving
them the room to utilize the information
that their
biologists their scientists
give to them
in managing wildlife and
i think that
it's important that we try to keep that
logic in mind as we vote on this bill so
i would not be in favor of this
thank you
representative i'm paul king right
representative king
thank you
representative uh harvey and
representative wolf can you turn off
so i i understand uh your point of view
that you want to
take the load off fish and game however
that is their job
that's why we appoint them
and that's why
they serve it is their job
rather than it's a pleasant job or not
is is not um
the issue
it is their job to set limits and set
seasons despite what the general public
may or may not think it is also their
job to
follow through with the petition process
which did not happen in this particular
case
so
it's it's hard for me to say well
on one hand
you know they don't have to do their job
because it's unpleasant it's partisan
and on the other hand we have we say
they have to do their job because it is
their job i also do not believe that
wildlife in new hampshire should be a
partisan issue i think
you know
good wildlife management benefits all of
new hampshire and the tourists that
comes in to our state and
so i would not like to see this bill or
any bill become a partisan issue thank
you
further discussion
seeing none clerk the motion on the
table is
ought to pass as amended with amendment
number zero one six six h the clerk will
thank you mr vice chair yes
representative close yes representative
spelaine yes representative howard
yes representative craig yes
representative love yes representative
wolf
yes
representative kittredge yes
representative allard yes
smith yes representative harvey no
representative leflam no representative
masamila
yes
representative king
no
the clerk votes no
representative egan
no
representative shirtless no
representative oxel
no
mr chair
chair vote yes
and now the vote should be 12 to 7.
on a vote 12 to 7 ought to pass motion
is adopted as a committee recommendation
who will be it will there be a commit
minority report and if so who will be
writing it
i guess i'll write it
representative reid will write it i will
write the majority report with that i
close the executive session in house
bill 1356 and move on to the executive
session open the executive session from
the house bill 1631
uh and representative that recognized
representative smith for a motion
thank you mr chairman i make a motion to
it's been moved by representative smith
and second by representative allard to
itl house bill
i'm sorry representative shirtless um
apologize for that mr speaker both good
looking uh yeah i i can see i'm confused
um the itl on house bill
1631. uh
i'll give it to representative smith for
to discuss his ideal motion and then
i'll i have a comment thank you mr
chairman so this bill was drafted on
behalf of a constituent who was disabled
you if you were here at the last
public hearing i read the testimony of
the person
this bill is paved with good intentions
but just because it's paid for good
intentions doesn't mean it's a good bill
it's got many flaws the biggest one is
financial impact two fishing game
um that's an estimate that's really hard
to come up with at this time so at this
point
the itl should stand
thank you
i'm going to make a comment on this bill
you'll see an amendment i'm passing
around on this bill
originally i looked at trying to figure
out
i'm concerned as we go forward in the
legislature every time we
force fish and game into giving a
discount
that affects their revenue right they
can have an increased number of hunters
but less money to be able to support
those same number of hunters and they're
only they're they're
they're funded through
fees and so their only avenue would be
if they give a discount to one hunter
they got to raise the price for another
hunter for the program
and i think that's diminishing returns
where they can get to a point where they
can't do their job
and so my idea was to create a
non-lapsing fund that the legislature
would fund that they could draw
the difference between what the citizen
pays for a discounted and what the full
price is and draw out of that fund um
the money so that fishing game can meet
whole so to speak i still think that's a
great idea
the problem is we didn't have enough
time to execute it and and and to do it
right so i wanted to i gave out the
amendment that i started drafting and
worked on um the other problem with it
was when i finally got the number from
fish and game on their expectation
because of this bill and the fact that
we're looking at all disabled people not
just veterans not just
paraplegics the number was 1.3 million
dollars roughly they were estimating
because they were looking at how many
people are you know look at census data
for how many people are fully disabled
in the state of new hampshire and what
potential of only 10 percent of those
people apply for licenses what would
that look like and you know it was an
ugly number right and so i wasn't ready
to bring a dollar figure to fund the
fund uh go through i did have a
conversation with the speaker's office
and if we had come to a decent
resolution they were willing to send it
over to probably ways and means because
it's a going to be a a new permanent
fund
that we'd be doing however it just isn't
quite ready for prime time but i want to
establish within the committee this
concept of every time we give a discount
fish and games the one that pays the
price and our hunters are the ones that
pay the price because
the fees come from the hunters and from
the trappers and from licenses and so
the only way fish and game can make up
that gap is to raise prices so the
legislature decides that we think
citizens should get a discount
and then we make every hunter and
fishermen pay for it right and if we're
going to do that if we the legislature
decide that we're going to give a
discount that we the legislature should
fund that and from that differential so
that agency can continue to do the
enforcement model that it needs
so i i not expecting any action on my
amendment i gave it to you so hopefully
maybe depending on what happens in the
next election depending on who's in
charge someone might bring forward an
amendment or a bill that might fill this
need and fix the problem
but we do have a diminishing returns
problem at fish and game and i am
concerned about it as the legislature
keeps doing this kind of work
and with that representative reid
thank you mr chair and i agree with you
on
making sure we fund that making sure
that the department has access to
general funds i also had spoken about an
amendment that i also after speaking
with ols and after speaking with the
licensing uh division
of the department realized it was far
too large of an of a
legislative change to to bring forth as
an amendment but i would like to see it
likewise as a future bill and that is
the idea that we are we have this kind
of
quilt this patchwork
hodgepodge kind of
discounting and free license structure
but and we're giving away these licenses
to people who would otherwise certainly
buy those licenses but we're giving it
away based on things like previous
occupation in terms of veteran status
disability and age in every single one
of those populations there are people
who are perfectly capable of buying
those licenses and there are people who
are not
if we stop giving the people who are
capable of buying the licenses free
licenses
and instead change the discount to
simply an income base we in my in my
discussions with people we talked about
something like 2x the poverty line or
something like that then what we're
doing is we're getting rid of all of the
revenue loss the department is
experiencing and we are bringing more
people into hunting we're getting more
people out in the woods and i would add
those are the right people to get out in
the woods because those are the people
most likely to need to use the meat who
are literally it's not even necessarily
a sport it's they are have to feed their
families
so um that's the thought that i've had
for the last several terms every time we
have one of these bills with a discount
um i think it's good for the department
to increase their revenue i think it's
good to get the right people out in the
woods and um having said that i
chose not to pursue an amendment because
it was too large for this particular
time thank goodness every
further comments representative wolff
um would it make sense to
pass the amendment and then interim
study the bill
again i thought about that but um again
i don't think it's
i i did it this way for particular
reasons because i think it we can i tl
that people have seen the amendment they
can you know these commit committee
members are passionate about fish and
game and they can bring it forward a new
bill next term
[Music]
saying no further discussion the clerk
will call the roll the motion is itl on
house bill 13 i'm sorry 1631.
mr vice chair yes representative close
yes representative spelaine yes
representative howard
yes
representative craig yes
representative love yes
representative wolf yes representative
kittredge
yes
representative allard yes
representative smith yes
representative harvey
yes
representative laflem yes
representative massimila yes
representative king yes
the clerk votes yes
representative egan yes
representative shirtless yes
representative oxal
yes
and mr chair
chair vote yes the vote is 19-0 and i'm
quite sure of that math on 19-0 without
objection will go on consent
with that i'll end the executive session
house bill 1631 and that concludes all
the business in front of the fish and
game committee i want to thank everybody
i will
i don't know if we're going to have any
senate bills coming over once we have
crossover um but if we do i'll be happy
to see your smiling faces sometime in uh
after march
so thank you very much guys have a great
i have a bill adjourned 10 30 in
you